there's been some extremely good
information that came in and I can tell
you it came in in April
to the chief prosecutor in Germany and
brownschweig that's Hans Christian
vultures and it came in very credible
source that brought in evidence that um
the body of Madeleine McCann May well be
in this reservoirs they're called the
bad again de arrade and it's a it's a
quite large expanse of water about 25-30
minutes from prezalush where she went
missing now this evidence came in and
Hans Christian Vault has double checked
it and immediately got in touch with um
the prosecutor in portamer a woman who's
been in charge there
since about 2014 and uh and top secret
they were able to pull this together and
kept this in completely quiet uh until
of course we heard about this uh just
over the weekend and um uh there are I
can tell you there's 10 German police
officers there's three as I understand
it British offices from operation Grange
and around 20 to 25 Portuguese police
involved in this search so it's it's
pretty comprehensive